yes there's a connection Megan Markel's
friends threw her a baby shower in New
York a couple months before her due date
in April she arrived at the Upper
Eastside venue yesterday amid tight
security the intimate party included
some big-name guests including Amal
Clooney Serena Williams and our very own
Queen Gayle King it was a former
American actresses first trip back to
the United States since her marriage to
Prince Harry at Windsor Castle last May
okay love it a good time was had by all
that's what I'll say what did you get
her well well if I told you know I'd
have to kill you because she didn't open
any of the gifts because she wants to do
that when she goes when she and Harry
are back together so I really don't know
what everybody got I think I got
something I think is very nice but you
know she's a very private person I think
she should decide what she wants to say
about this but I hope she won't mind me
sharing this because I've never seen
anything like this at a baby shower
they did flower decorations they had set
flower arranging they brought in
somebody to explain how to arrange
flowers we all each made an individual
vase and then Megan at the request got
in touch with an organization I've never
heard of repeat roses and all of those
are donated to different charities no I
thought that was a very sweet thing I
mean it just speaks to who she is she's
very kind she's very generous and a
really really sweet person yeah I think
her friends just wanted to celebrate her
Serena and her best friend who's been
her best friend since she was 17 we all
have best friend Genevieve and her
friend Jessica Mulroney
those were the three women that put it
all together and it was a very very
small private affair and just a very
special time for her baby is a great we
were talking about this it's the most
special time in your life yes getting
ready for the birth those hours are a
lot of fun I think their gift was big I
bet it's a good one good things come in
little packages they do they do there
are no bad baby gifts no yeah that's
true